what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to dojo cat
eight [ __ ] but before i start do not
forget to subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell as you guys know
each and every one of you helps me get
to 20 000 subscribers which is my goal
and um yeah so
why am i so awkward wait is my mic
working let me double check
okay i think it's working all right you
guys hear that
yeah okay
this happened one two three
times too much
these dumbass snickers
[Music]
wow wow oh my gosh this is what the
manosphere talks about like girls songs
about guys
look at what you did listen to your
[Music]
friends
[Music]
okay so her first point is that men are
trash like
i'm just going to be honest that's all
she's saying
i can't even really get mad at them they
fall then i got a face punch
guys rap music is growing on me and like
hip-hop
whatever you classify this i'm bopping
my head i can't
i can't deny it
could have made her back but he broke
and he still went like a chill and he
really think i'm gonna get back to him
doing too much relax a bit acting like
that cause your dad's a [ __ ]
must be the way that the planet is must
be your face cause it's not your dick
i'm a freak not a masochist should have
known you had the baddest [ __ ]
left on redding can't give head really
you ain't
[Music]
okay so she's saying you should have
knew what you had
before it was gone like snap
snap let let him know
[Music]
okay i would not i don't just you guys
know i don't agree with that message
i'm i i really i'm not the type to say
i hate men all that stuff um
however however
i can't deny that her voice is good and
i'm bopping my head
[Music]
damn so she's saying if you're not gonna
put a ring on it
if you're not gonna give me that
girlfriend title it's not cheating i can
do what i want
snap you kept secrets and your cousins
[Music]
i'll call your [ __ ] mom
[Music]
but i'm gonna be honest guys don't girls
don't listen to this
not all better trash if she picks guys
that are trash
to date that's her own problem like
that that's her own fault because she
doesn't know how to pick guys
don't don't let her
influence your view of an entire gender
but
i can't help but shimmy
[Music]
okay um that was
okay i give this song i was bopping my
head but i hate the message so i gotta
give it a two out of five
not not my favorite um i like her voice
i like the you know beat or whatever but
i hated all the lyrics except i did like
the one that said it's not cheating if i
wasn't with your ass i just i felt like
that had like the um like the you know
like
take it but no that attitude is very
unattractive so don't do that ladies
but let me know in the comments if you
guys agree or disagree do not forget to
subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell i'm gonna
talk to you guys next time